bello e tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono la vj ed oggi siamo
sulla seconda parte del blog speciale in
texas quini buona visione
sono tutti ragazzi
no dai a patisca ci siamo in mezzo alla
strada come di buoni italiani all'estero
non esiste il marciapiede è bellissimo
che in america non usano le macchine
sono i cavalli perché la 1000 le
macchine sono troppo menti
sono al telefono ovviamente come sempre
no la serata di ieri si è spinta
leggermente non troppo oltre quest'uomo
sta male ciao papi
ma per credere magari prendendo
ma in calena dio
di guidare questo
e buconi ok ragazzi prestate attenzione
alla genialità di quest'uomo allora
brothers lo vedete quello scuolabus
laggiù stile proprio america
l'obiettivo è quello di arrivarci solo
che siamo in un parcheggio e dovremo
fare un giro incredibile per arrivare
fino lì solo che nei prati del texas non
sappiamo se ci sono serpenti e altissimo
all'erba io sono il bermuda dobbiamo
correre come fai di
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il solito è il primo
antichi aedi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
basta ricadendo su due c'è una mazzata è
vero che l'unico modo perché sono
sacrosanti di scappare messicane per
venire da me è uno che ti guarda
stranissimo dalla macchina facile che
qua tutti possa perdere ma dove cazzo
sei perdo sempre a zio tutta la pista
del circuito apprendimenti ci passano le
moto un metro e mezzo per niente raga io
non so che dire essere conservare la
gara con vale e figo
dallapè che questo mi sa che mi vanto
ragazzi non pensavo di poter registrare
quattro hanno detto colpa sua che nel
caso mi arrestano siamo nella griglia di
barche sulla griglia di partenza della
dannata cela cameraman e cameramen
insomma ragazzi più pizzini di così
punto più vicino di questa la moto che
non ci conviene tanto bravo ciao
in quel momento in cui c'è l'attore di
matrix che sa fare foto con tutti ma lui
non sa in realtà sono io vederlo ci dica
sì sono io l'eletto e sbagliata inizia
la mia inter ap media regalo fatto la
foto con kanye rings i latori di matrix
incredibili per niente passato perché
l'accesso e ovviamente come dei buoni
fanno fanno braccano gli attori anche
accidenti pensiamo alla gara
manca veramente poco adesso arriva male
ecco vale
by vale grandissimo vediamo vada bene
noi siamo qua in questo posto dove se ci
viene la voglia di suicidarci è anche
aperto quindi possiamo correre in pista
mentre passa qualcuno e buttarci nel
mezzo a vedere da ridere vero anche
ostina
adesso moro rilascio
lombardo
mettete le fette
ma dove cazzo sarà fa vj e chi infine
dal padre ha fatto siamo per commentare
la musica si rischia la morte di
filippide chiamo violetta aimar ciò che
completano c'è questo problema
[Musica]
abbiamo io mi si possono bloccare la
gomma come sta funzionando la moto e
come sarà più o meno caldo la sua atroce
il meteo vedete dovesse rimanere qui i
dispetti di guido meda anche lei di che
continua a martellare molto forte e
quinto tempo per le di che normale non è
vero non è fottutamente vero non è
possibile avere attinenza da seguire
vale su instagram i segue vale su
instagram a me la passerà fra temi seme
vale su instagram davvero davvero e
lasciate che siano i miti della faccia
che è vero sì davvero vicenda davvero
oddio sono diventato prossimo anche per
questo nasce ecco cos'è dai ma c è
scoraggiato là dentro
praticamente se tu vai clive susseguiti
pechino xix secolo e gran bel ragazzo in
gamba il ragazzo perfetti avrà anche
laicato a spero la foto che siamo due
figli trappola svizzeri a da vinci
birreria e wine card
ma che cazzo signore signori pizzeria
paparazzi
molto c'è un casino pazzesco
si balla si canta si vede
[Musica]
non si vede nel video ma la bava alla
bocca ma che cosa stracazzo ci fa un
hummer della roma ad austin in texas
stiamo per fare il classico scherzo mai
visto quello dove ti siedi su questo
caso e fa le scoregge c'è proprio una
cosa che non si è mai vista nella storia
gli interessi siamo arrivati a milano
adesso sono tipo c'è un jet lag che non
hai testo per crepare è praticamente
ragazzi è successo che mentre ero
sull'aereo di ritorno non trovavo il
cellulare vol avevo perso non lo trovo
più quella voi infilato nella tasca
davanti del sedile e quindi niente non
lo trovo più e per cercarlo tipo mi sono
spogliato guardato ovunque ho appoggiato
ovunque le cose poi vabbè l'ho trovato
quindi tutto a posto siamo scesi
dall'aereo e quando scendi dall'aereo
devi dare il passaporto perché devi far
capire che sei italiano ovunque dei fa
capire dove sei e non trovano più il
passaporto che prima c'avevo perché
quando mi sono sbagliato per provare il
tempo a cercare il telefono ce l'avevo
niente sono riuscito a perdere il
telefono passaporto tutto perso in un
secondo è quindi ragazzi questo era il
blog in texas in sunto questo è quello
che è successo è stato veramente un
viaggio bellissimo incredibile a parte
il jet lag alla fine però grazie ancora
il team di milestone per avermi invitato
a questo incredibile evento e quindi
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto quel momento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come ridotto tenere
schizzati come ultima cosa ragazzi non
dimenticatevi che domani c'è la puntata
speciale in live di happy meals per il
centesimo episodio quindi non mancate
e ci vediamo io vado a fare qualche
bella lì